لم يقتصر التهكم من خطاب بنفير الاخير على
رفاقه في الكنيست فما كادت قدماه تان
الارض حتى ضجت وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
بالحديث عن خطاب الماعز كما وصفته مع كثير
من السخريه لكن وان ضحك كثيرا في السابق
فبن فير حتما لا يرى في وضعه السياسي
الحالي ما يثير
السخريه ففي خطابه ذاك الذي لقي تفاعلا
كبيرا عبر بنفير عن معارضته الشديده
اتفاقيه تبادل مع حماس ترددت تفاصيلها في
وسائل الاعلام دون تاكيدها رسميا ووصف
الصفقه بانها معزه تم اطلاقها لتمهد
الارضيه لصفقه فاقده للشرعيه بكل المقاييس
مضيفا ان الذين سقطوا من الجيش ومن
المواطنين ليسوا ماعزا لاهم ولا اهاليهم
ولم يكن مفاجئا ان بنفير لم يتطرق في
خطابه ل
136 اسيرا لازالوا في غزه والذين التقى
نتنياهو بعائلاتهم قبل بضعه ايام وتعهد
لهم ان الاولويه عنده هي اعاده ابنائهم
حتى لو كان الثمن ائتلافه الحكومي ولربما
كان هذا هو التعهد الذي اثار حفيظه بنفير
بصفته وزيرا في هذا الائتلاف الحكومي
وابرز الرافضين لوقف الحرب لان معنى كلام
نتنياهو ان بنغ فير سيكون معز فداء يضحى
به مع سموتريتش رفيقه في الكفاح كثمن
لاتمام الصفقه التي بات نتنياهو ما يبدو
مجبرا عليها امام ضغوط داخليه وخارجيه
اثقلت كاهله ومخاوف بنفير ليست نابعه من
اعتبار الكثيرين له شخصيه متطرفه
وشعبوية خوف بنفير من اخبار افادت ان
نتنياهو ارسل اشارات لير لابيد زعيم
المعارضه مرحبا به في حكومه الائتلاف
ليحول لابيد واعضاء من حزبه محل بينغ فيرو
سموتريتش وزيران ليس صدفه انهما صاخب جدا
في معارضه الصفقه ولن يشفع لهما انهما
طالما غنيا في جوقه نتنياهو
سابقا في حين حللت وسائل اعلام اخرى تلك
الاشاره بالقول ان هدفها ايهام بنفير بان
نتنياهو مستعد للتخلي عنه لدفعه لتليين
موقفه الرافض للصفقه التي يحتمل ان
نتنياهو بات يرى فيها الضوء الاخير في نفق
الحرب التي
اعلنها حرب عجزت عن انقاذ ولو اسيرا
اسرائيليا واحدا من غزه رغم انه تعهد بفعل
ذلك مرات تجاوزت عدد ايام الحرب التي بلغت
120 يوما ويبدو ان بنفير لا يحسن سقاط
الاشارات التي التقطها غريمه يا اير لابيد
والذي صرح بانه مستعد لدخول حكومه نتنياهو
ولو مؤقتا من اجل اتمام صفقه التبادل
لتتصدر الصحف بعد ذلك عناوين تشير لترحيب
الليكود بالخطوه وتوحي وكان لابيد على وشك
ان يخطو خطوته الاولى في الحكومه لولا
نتنياهو ومزاجه الذي يتقلب حيث ما تتقلب
مصالحه فرئيس الحكومه رغم كل ما تقدم عاد
وخلط الاوراق كعا وصرح بلاءات ثلاث لن
يتنازل
عنها لن ننهي الحرب لن نخرج الجيش من
القطاع ولن نطلق راح الاف المخربين حتى
القضاء على حماس تصريحات وصفتها معاريف
بانها تصحيح مسار من قبل نتنياهو ليعود
لجاد بنفير بعد تهديدات الاخير بالانسحاب
من الحكومه في حال تمت الصفقه دون القضاء
على حماس لكن لاءات نتنياهو اصطدمت بلاءات
اصدقاء يملك نتنياهو من قبضتهم مفرا لا
لتهجير اهل غزه ولا لاعاده احتلال القطاع
ولا لتوسيع الصراع لاءات القت بثقلها ولا
شك على نقاشات المجلس الوزاري الموسع الذي
بحث امس مقترح الصفقه الاخير وايا كان ما
يضمره نتنياهو يبدو ان بينغ فير بات عبء
حتى على الاقربين مثل بيتس ليل سموتريتش
خليله سياسيا وايديولوجية
صوته مهاجما بنفير وقائلا له ان الشراكه
لا تكون بالركض لوسائل الاعلام ونشر
التهديدات
بي لا ينسى احد ان الحرب انطلقت على ايقاع
هم حيوانات بشريه لكن غد ايقاعها
اليوم لسنا ماعزا وبين هذا وذاك اختارت
صحيفتها ارتس في كاريكاتور الاخير ان
تصوره ثورا هائجا يبتهج نتنياهو في ترويضه
باستعمال علم يقطر دماء هي على الارجح
دماء المدنيين في
غزه وسواء كان عنزا او ثورا يبدو ان بنفير
باتلا يسمع كل الجلبه التي يحدثها ولا
يعقل انه قريبا قد يساق بعيدا عن حظيره
التاثير بعد ان ناطح بتصريحاته الجميعه
وضاق به الراعي
والرعيه